you've won two n-double-a-cp Awards
congratulations I think that happened
since I saw you last yeah so and then so
that was good luck and then I get all
the credit and then you went to the
Emmys this year because of black-ish
yeah black-ish was nominated yeah and I
got to ask you I don't know if you've
been the Emmys before what was your
favorite part of the of going to the
show getting dressed up like all my
favourite celebrities right meeting
Oprah was that you met Oprah yes I did
that's insane you mean Oprah Oprah was
there and now how did that happen did
you go up to her how did you how did
this whole Oprah thing happen at the
Emmys yeah so she was all the way in the
front row
yeah that's Oprah all right me if I'd
seen brother miles that plays on the
show my TV Tim brother yeah so we were
like so nervous I was like okay okay
let's get our stuff together like we're
about to meet Oprah like this is a goal
of ours yeah so we go down and when I
meet her like her smile like it was
amazing like I felt like I should have
got a car then like you feel that you
should have been given a car at that
point look under your seat there's got
to be some kind of prize yeah must be we
have a picture of you meeting with Oprah
this is a nice you look so happy and
you're we're your eyes closed the whole
time no it wasn't but I just felt that
you know oh god I felt like it was real
yeah when Oprah hugs you it's like you
travel through time
you